Next, we're going to speak with Dr.
Josh Mandel who earned a B.S.
in Computer Science at MIT and an M.D.
degree at Tufts University School
of Medicine.
Currently, he's Chief Architect for
the Smart Platform Project
at the Boston Children's Hospital and
Harvard Medical School.
So Josh, I really appreciate you taking
the time to be with the students today.
I sometimes think of you
as a younger version of me.
So could you tell the students
a little bit about your background?
>> Sure.
Well these days the main hat that
I'm wearing is I'm the architect for
a project called Smart Platforms
at Boston Children's Hospital,
Harvard Medical School.
But I have a background
in computer science and
did undergrad in
computer science at MIT.
I spent a little bit of time working
at a biotech startup in Cambridge,
Mass doing gene synthesis and
laboratory automation.
And I want to medical school at Tufts.
I graduated in 2010 and
realized I was having
a lot of fun trying to fix
thecomputer systems in hospitals and
clinics and I've been working hard since
then in the health informatics space.
>> That's great.
You've been involved I guess since
the beginning with the SHARP Project at
Harvard Children's Hospital.
Could you tell us
a little bit about that?
>> Yeah, that's right.
Sure.
So back in 2009, early 2010, the Office
of the National Coordinator for
Health IT Sponsored four research
projects or put out proposals for
four research projects.
One in the area of security,
one in the area of data normalization,
one in the area of cognitive aspects
of using EHRs and one in the area of
building app platforms on top of
electronic health record systems.
And that last one is a project called
SMART that I've been working on
at Harvard since 2010.
And it's all about trying to build
app platforms so that doctors and
patients and healthcare practitioners
can use the applications that they want
to to interact with health data.
The idea was, we've got iPhones
in our civilian lives and
Android phones that let us use
whatever apps that we want.
And wouldn't it be nice in health care
if we could bring the app that we wanted
to the table to work
with patient record data.
>> This idea of app platforms
is something that a number of
people are interested in.
Tell us why you feel it's important and
what approach did Harvard
take to developing one.
>> Yeah, so we have a lot of health care
data, some of which patients bring to
the table, some of which are measured
in a traditional clinical setting.
And those data live inside of a variety
of different databases inside of
hospital and clinics.
And, when it comes to making sense of
an entire patient, to make a decision,
to figure out a diagnosis, to decide
on a kind of treatment, it's extremely
helpful to be able to bring those
data together in one place and
to use specific tools that
help to do a specific job.
So, this is something that we're pretty
used to in terms of an app platform on
the phone, or you might use a specific
tool just to manage your calendar and
a different tool to
manage your to do list.
And if there's a better calendar
application that comes along, or
a better to do list that comes along,
you can trade information with
your friends and
find the best one that works for you.
And we'd like to be able to do the same
thing with the way that we make
a diagnosis, or make a treatment for
a diabetic patient,
or engage in communicating with
patients in a clinical setting.
We'd like to be able to encourage
app developers to build
the best tools to do these
small kinds of jobs and
give end users the freedom to pick
the tools that really work for them.
So there have been a number of
approaches to these kinds of
app platform development and what
we're doing at Harvard and with smart
platforms is to build an open set of
specifications built on open standards
that anyone can implement without any
proprietary technology in the stacks.
So we want to make sure that all the
specifications we build are out there on
the web for people to build on top of.
>> Well along came HIMSS 2014.
And I ran into you there.
And to my surprise and delight you
were showing a new version of SMART.
Can you tell us about that?
>> Sure.
So
we were very excited coming into
the HIMSS conference which is
the Health Information Management
Systems Society conference in Orlando
this past February where we were able to
get three or four different EHR vendors
that come together and implement
support for the same set of apps.
So we had some apps that we had built
ourselves on the SMART platforms team
and other apps that had been built by
independent application developers.
And we were able to get this same
package of apps running on top of
a commercial EHR system from a company
called Cerner on top of an open source
electronic health record called Vista,
which this instance of Vista
was maintained by Hewlett-Packard
in their government innovation lab.
We were also able to show these same
apps running on top of a system called
Help2 that runs at Intermountain
Healthcare in Salt Lake City.
So it was a really exciting time
because we were able to take some new,
emerging standards from HL7
which is the healthcare
standards development organization and
build this app
platform on top of an open set of
standards that EHR vendors and
large healthcare providers
organizations, and Hewlett-Packard and
government innovation lab,
were all able to integrate consistently.
>> And more specifically,
that new standard was FHIR.
>> So yes, we've been doing a lot
of work recently with FHIR,
Fast Healthcare Interoperability
Resources which provide a couple of
key building blocks when you're thinking
about building a health app platform.
And so the first important
building block that FHIR
provides is a set of
clinical data models.
So how do you write down a medication or
an allergy or a problem or
a lab result or
a set of patient demographics?
And FHIR provides detailed data models,
which are called resources for
each of those things.
And the second building block
that FHIR provides is an API,
an application programming interface.
And this is one that's built on ADTP and
REST, that let's you query for
the specific kinds of discrete data
elements that you're interested in.
So if you're trying to build
a lab Data viewing app
you can write a restful query or
pull back the lab results that
you're interested in from a system
that implements this FHIR API.
So FHIR has been a really
important building block for
the current version of SMART which
is entirely based on open standards.
>> Well can you show us a little bit?
>> Yeah I would be delighted
to show you what the SMART and
FHIR platform looks like.
So, I mentioned that Smart is a platform
where third party app developer's
can build apps that hook into EHR's.
And I'm going to start off by
showing you, not a real EHR, but
kind of the demo sandbox system
that we host at Harvard.
So, we won't be looking at
any real patient data, but
you'll see a set of synthetic and
anonymized patient data.
And anybody who wants to try this at
home can go to fhir.smartplatforms.org
and create an account and
go through the same app and the same
demo that I'll be showing you here.
But this fake EHR that I'll start out
with just does two very simple jobs.
It let's you find a patient.
And then it let's you run another app.
So I'll show you an example
of a growth charts app
that we built at
Boston Children's Hospital.
And I'm going to pick
a pediatric record here.
I'm going to search for
a patient called Amy Lee.
And I'm going to open this
record in the Growth Charts App.
And what we'll see when this
launches is two different views of
a patient's growth history.
We decided it was really important to
build apps that made sense not just for
clinicians but for patients as well.
So we won't get deep into
the features of this app.
But I'll point out at a really high
level this app is able to fetch the data
that it needs from the SMART EHR
that's running on the other end.
And when it gets those data, it's able
to plot the traditional kinds of growth
curves that you see on
a paper growth chart.
So the initial view that we'll see here
will show me the child's length or
height, as well as their weight.
And we can see how it's
been tracking over time.
And this is an app that built
entirely using HTML and JavaScript.
It runs entirely client side in the web
browser, so the only server side
component of this app is just a static
web server that hosts this HTML and
JavaScript, and the app itself is
all just running in the browser.
So this is a traditional kind of
clinician-facing view that let's me see
how growth has been tracking in
terms of percentiles over time.
But also built into this app
is a communication tool,
so we can have a conversation
with parents as well
that highlights a few of the key
aspects of a child's growth.
So in this example we see this is
a patient with a healthy weight, and so
rather than getting bogged down in a lot
of curves and numbers that are changing
over time, the real essential message
for a conversation with Amy's parents
here might be that Amy has a healthy
weight for her height and for her age.
And we can see that her weight has
been trending in a healthy fashion
since her last visit.
So this an app that we built.
It's available open source, so
anybody can take the code for
this application and run it, or
extend it to fit their needs.
And it's an application that you're
seeing here running against what
we call our sandbox server with 50 or
60 sample patients of data.
>> And I believe the app is
called Growth-Tastic!, just so
the students have the name.
>> Yeah, well, the official name is it's
the SMART Pediatric Growth Chart App,
but when we want to sound jazzy about
it, we'll call it Growth-Tastic!
And if it's interesting, Mark,
I could show you a little bit about what
the data looked like under
the hood when this app runs.
>> I think it'd be great.
>> Okay, so let me actually open up
the Chrome developer tools here and
show you what happens when
we load this app again.
So what I want to show you is,
as this app loads,
the set of API calls that it makes in
order to get data from the smart EHR.
We won't talk about the details of
authorization on authentication right
now but I'll just say that under the
hood the app is getting access tokens
that it needs to fetch
clinical data using oloft2.
But once it's got those access tokens
it's able to make a couple of very
simple API calls in order
to fetch clinical data.
The first one here is a call
to get patient demographics.
And so the call itself is just
/patient/880378, which the patient
ID in this case, and what we get back
is a FHIR response which is a JSON
representation of patient demographics
which has the patient's name,
the patient's birthdate, medical
record numbers, other identifiers.
And we can see just at a glance, this
is the kind of payload that a developer
could look at, inspect and
make sense of pretty quickly.
And if there are any fields that you
didn't understand the FHIR specification
which is hosted on the web defines each
one of these fields in great detail.
So that's what the patient
demographics look like.
And I'll show you just one more example.
This app only needs to make one other
API call which is to fetch vital signs.
So heights and weights and
body mass indexes.
And in fHIR all those things
are called observations.
So the app is able to fetch just
the observations that it needs
about a patient's growth over time.
And I'll give you just a really quick
look at what those observations look
like when they come over the wire.
So we're looking right now at the FHIR
JSON representation of an observation.
And in this case it's a body
mass index observation.
And we can see that this is a quantity
of 16.9 kilograms per meter squared.
And it was taken in 2008.
So again, this is the JSON
representation of a set of FHIR data.
And this is over the wire the kind of
raw information that's fueling this app.
Once the app fetches
patient demographics and
a set of these observations
from the EHR, it's able to draw
the visualization that you see here on
this screen based just on those data.
>> Josh, I know in addition
to what you've shown us,
you're interested in the idea that
many people refer to as Pull.
Can you talk a bit about how
you're using other technologies to
enable patients to effectively
subscribe to receive their own data.
>> Sure.
So the work that I've been doing with
my SMART platform architect hat on
has been really focused on
building tools that let
clinicians launch an app from
an electronic health record system or
that let patients launch an app from
inside of a patient portal online.
But I've also been
very involved with some
efforts at the level of federal
work groups to define standards and
specifications that let patients
access their own data online.
So right now in 2014 as part
of meaningful use stage two
patients have the ability to view their
data online through a patient portal,
and to download it and to transmit it
to a third party app that they choose.
And typically the way that transmission
happens is through something called
Push Messaging or the Direct Project,
which works like secure email.
I've been very interested in
trying to define standards for
a different kind of mechanism for
apps to access data.
So instead of basically emailing your
data to the app, we can have a web API
where apps ask for data and patients can
authorize access to those data or not.
And so we've defined a set
of specifications called
the Blue Button REST API that have
enabled anyone with health data, so
an EHR vendor or a healthcare provider
organization, to expose patient data for
patients who want to authorize
access to third party applications.
It's a very similar set of technology
to what we've been doing with SMART.
But a different set of use cases and
a different set of end users.
>> This is great.
I want the students to reflect back on
the interview with Doug Fridsma much
earlier in the course,
when he talked about the idea of using
Internet to move health IT into
a new era of interoperability.
And I think that, Josh,
you've just shown us a real live
example of doing just that.
And I really appreciate your
taking the time to do it.
I hope this is something the students
find exciting and maybe some of them
will decide to do what you and
I did and actually go into this field.
Thank you again.
>> Thanks very much, Mark.
It's been my pleasure.